I get a lot of hate let's go through
some of the fun ones that my team pulled
we'll see him working at Starbucks soon
loser how much did the fake private jet
cost you loser if you do anything worth
doing there will be people who oppose
you and they will throw rocks at you and
attack and I want to break down how I've
dealt with it going from 1 75 million
for the last 2 years so you can too so I
want to walk through kind of two
Frameworks that I think through when
dealing with hate NE ity people calling
you a liar first things first this is
the quick and dirty and then I'll get a
little bit more nuanced so when someone
attacks you you have three options as I
see it if the claim they are making has
an element of Truth at level one you
have ignore this is what I would
consider my all-time heavyweight
champion of the world personal
preference ignoring it cost me the least
amount of time the least amount of
effort and and this is a very very
important one they're choosing to
advertise me they're choosing to take
all their hard-earned attention their
eyes the Goodwill they have in their
audience and say hey everyone look at
Alex what a gift and the crazy thing is
is that when people direct their
customers towards you some of them buy
that's what's mind-blowing to me I'm
like thank God like loser 29 like I hope
you keep doing this cuz it just
continues to fill my bank account that
being said ignore cost you the least
there's no effort on your behalf it's
amazing this is why it's probably one of
my all-time favorite ways to deal with
most things in life I'll give you the
quote that my dad told me many many
times in my life he said God gave you
the power to ignore use it the second
this one takes effort agree I think Gary
popularized the concept of Eminem
winning the rap battle I am white I am a
[__] I do live in a trailer with my
mom the other guy couldn't talk [__]
about him is he claimed every single
negative thing that was about him here
tell these people something they don't
know about
me if someone says hey Alex you're such
an egotistical douchebag and you don't
care about other people I could agree
yeah man I suck what do they say now
there's nothing to say and it just
silences it because the thing is is that
conflict only goes on as long as there's
an equal or opposing Force as soon as
you step to their side of the table
there's nothing to push against there's
only one person allowed in the angry
boat and so what you can do is you get
in the angry boat with them and you say
I know I suck and then they have to get
out because if they agree with you then
what it just eliminates the conflict
there's nothing left to talk about and
then you move on with your life now the
third level of this is what I would
consider Ninja level agree plus one or
one up them so if someone says Alex
you're an egotist I could say dude you
don't know the half of it I do this and
this and this insult yourself better
than they can and you should know how to
do it better than they can cuz you know
you better than they do too so this is
the quick and dirty 95% of the conflict
are the attacks that you'll get you
usually you can deal with with this
three-step process if you haven't seen
this there's an unbelievable scene in
Ted lasso where Nate his former Protege
gets on the camera live and talks a
bunch of [__] about him and says that
he's an idiot he doesn't know what he's
doing whatever fast forward to the press
conference where they're asking Ted
lasso and he handles it perfectly from a
PR perspective and he actually uses
number three he says oh man Nate said
that about me man he could have said
this he could have said this he could
have said he could have made fun of my
hey but that's Nate the great for you
you know he's the same way on the pitch
you know he'll find the tiniest little
weakness in a team and just want to
attack that and then the whole crew of
newscasters just start laughing because
there's nothing else to say now if he
had then attacked back then it would
have become this whole drama but after
that it's done he puts it to rest and
then Nate looks vicious for attacking
somebody who has a sense of humor now
the second category if someone lies they
accuse you of lying about something this
is something called an Extinction curve
a CL example would be like I could yell
at a rock and if I keep yelling at a
rock at some point I will stop yelling
at the Rock why cuz the rock doesn't
give me any feedback and so what we want
to be in the situation is The Rock when
you are ignoring you are just you a
stone they can do whatever they want it
doesn't affect you and I love this
position because you are greater than
hate only comes from Below in my entire
life it has never come from above and so
if someone hates on you just take that
as mental note of the fact that they're
below you and they concede the fact that
they follow you and so based on the
person who's hating on you they will
maybe hate on you one time and then
disappear or hate on you two times and
then disappear but if you don't respond
they will eventually disappear it is
just a fact of life unless they get
reinforcement they will disappear and
that's why I just choose not to engage I
also don't like wasting my time now
let's go into the ugly scenarios of what
if what they're saying is basically
calling you a liar around something core
uh to your brand or what you've been
known
for here's my little box
so you've got bigger than you smaller
than you and then they said you lied
about something or they said something
else so let's start with the easiest one
someone smaller than you and they just
said Alex has big ears I can ignore them
I could agree and be like hell yeah I
got big ears you should see what else
number three I could be like not only do
I have big ears I could one up them like
they're actually even worse when it
rains cuz then I catches all the water
and then my back gets wet it's a whole
problem believe me my wife will tell you
now all of a sudden there's nothing they
can say so you do the one two three
process here you pick whichever one you
want and all three of them will serve
you let's go into slightly harder
territory they're smaller than you but
they're basically calling you out on a
lie that could threaten your reputation
they say you falsified claim something
along those lines which typically comes
to just honesty which is one of the
things that the whole world hates the
world forgive just about anything except
for a liar kind of interesting now in my
opinion I'm just giving you the Alex
Playbook I
ignore that's it I ignore it as painful
as it is and to see them you know
frothing at the mouth and the common
threads they have go back and forth
never once have I made less money from
anyone doing this because think about
this the only way that you combat their
message is by being louder with yours
not directing your traffic to them and
so you ignore them Plus
us you amplify because every moment that
I spend addressing them I stop giving
value to my audience so in a very real
way attacks have taken people down but
because of how they responded not
because of the strength of the attacker
they take someone off their game then
they get in this Petty pissing match
with someone who's lower than them and
it makes them look bad even if you win
you lose it's a pic Victory you lose
credibility people see a different side
of you all of that's bad and so I prefer
to pretend you don't exist and then 10x
my message and tell everyone who's on my
team these [__] are lying and trying
to destroy us the only way that you beat
hate is you don't beat hate you drown it
out and as a second point to this
someone can hate on you who's below you
and get you to respond it means that
they control you they are in control of
your actions how weak does that appear I
want to be a rock I want somebody to be
whatever the [__] they want to do and I
will continue to be a rock that's at
least how I perceive these types of
situations use it if useful but ignore
and amplify now we've covered box one
and two so these are the easy ones if
someone's bigger than you and they say
something
else you one two three of them same as
before and what I recommend is really
lean into number three just eviscerate
yourself so there was a major news
Outlet like re top five you know who
this news person is attacked somebody
who's in the porn industry and they were
discrediting and saying man look at what
this generation has come to and it was
just a video of a bunch of girls jumping
in the pool whatever and so they
responded because everyone tagged and
knew who they were and so they said you
should join us next time now the news
anchor was trying to hate on them but
they just made a joke out of it what's
the coolest way to respond just make a
joke out of it and what does he look
like super Petty what do they look like
fun and awesome and what did they do
that next day record
sales he chose to use his platform to
direct attention to theirs for free
didn't have to pay affiliate commissions
what a steal we should only hope that
someone bigger than us hates on us rule
number one never attack back you cannot
win by attacking you win by deflection
or by amplifying above you never win in
direct conflict when it comes to
reputation now in the last box someone
bigger than you tries to discredit you
how do you respond so there's a mega
influencer and I saw this influencer
that I followed for many many years make
all these posts about kind of denying
this claim that they were getting
attacked for so this was a lie that many
people were trying to attack them with
and it was specifically a competitor of
theirs that was trying to defame them
right really petty stuff but tough for
that individual because they built their
whole career off of this particular um
truth I'm just going to read The
Exchange to you I said uh can I suggest
something I believe that brand is built
on associations if I stand next to
something and say I am not a pink
elephant people will over enough time
associate me and the Pink Elephant
replace pink elephant with whatever you
are claiming you are not think about
that for a second this is me cutting to
you who's listening or watching this
right now if you keep saying I'm not
that way I'm not that I'm not that all
that people remember is you and that
that's it so you keep repeating that and
you actually feed into the narrative
you're trying to disprove although
well-intentioned I don't think these
posts help you for context I didn't know
you were dealing with this but then you
drew my attention to it so you used your
platform to increase awareness of your
enemy's message the only way you could
combat hate is to get louder you shrink
them into irrelevance you don't win on
logic you win by force because you'll
never convince them you can make them so
small they cease to matter take it or
leave it just my opinion but I've
studied brand deeply in creating mind
from zero and I get plenty of hate and
people who say I faked my business
success and that I make up my numbers
Etc I gain Nothing by drawing attention
to them no one follows you because of
this particular reason that that the
person was worried about I said they
follow you because of the value you
provide them and let's face it even if
someone did think that you weren't this
one particular thing it doesn't affect
them at all it doesn't change their
behavior anyways I'm just saying this if
you didn't reply nothing would happen
your following won't stop growing you
won't stop making sales only reply to
people bigger than you I'm just giving
you brand strategy if you want to
respond I respect it I just tell you
what I would do which is nothing focus
on winning be louder take the anxious
energy and put it into your megaphone
about your mission another saying I like
is they're not worth the skin off the
back of your knuckles the law of large
numbers makes it appear as though the
world hates you humans aren't built to
get this much feedback imagine you're 85
years old and saggy and no longer look
how you do now will you care about this
blip and I say this to say that if you
get 500 hateful comments that's .1% of
your audience the other
99.9% love you focus on them and right
now you're moving up and so that means
the bigger the game the bigger the
dragons also all these people based on
the nature of this particular person the
hate was also laced on the fact that
they couldn't have done as well as they
did without Faking It basically and so I
said they're just complimenting you like
that's all this hate fundamentally is so
take that insult as a compliment instead
it only bothers you because you choose
to let it bother you and so I'd sent
this particular person the story of uh
Lela getting called to skinny [__] by
some dude who walked past her she was
like did you hear that called me skinny
and so even though the guy meant it as
an insult she took it as a compliment
which means the entire thing was just
based on our subjective choice of how we
choose to take these things and said so
it only bothers you because you let it
otherwise they're just sending you
traffic they're choosing to promote you
for free what a deal I said can you ask
them to send some to me too I would just
like the extra attention but let them
know that I won't return the favor just
to be clear I'm not sending my traffic
to them so I finalized all of this stuff
with just saying if it's true lean into
it if it's false and they're smaller
ignore it if it's false and they're
bigger make them seem Petty and Beyond
those actions you only win by getting
louder you don't silence say you drown
it out you only lose if you get quieter
or you change your
message and so you get quieter by not
saying anything at all which in a way
stops delivering value to your audience
or you change the message you have to
your audience because you're no longer
providing value to them and directing
them elsewhere in either scenario
the only solution is value because the
only thing anyone will care about is
value and if they came there for the
value they will stay there for the value
and most times those people will attack
the people who are trying to discredit
you because they love the value that you
give them and they don't want it to stop
but no matter what no one keeps
attacking someone who does not reply and
if you just keep getting bigger and keep
getting louder and keep providing more
and more value you weather the storm it
has happened every time in my life and
I've had some crazy people come after me
and you know what long enough time
Rising Extinction curves always rule if
you yell at a rock long enough you walk
away yes even these big ones where it
feels the worst where they're
discrediting the biggest thing one 2
3 ignore agree one up if you can so
somebody was being discredited so was an
athlete for being not natural so being
accused of taking steroids this was a
girl now all these people are trying to
attack her and
I thought that the most elegant response
that she could have done hey guys you
got me I'm not
natural my boobs are
fake my hair it's actually a darker
brown and my eyelashes peel them off
these are actually fake too and hold on
let me take this makeup remover thing
and smear it off my face and yep I wear
makeup too and so you got me the rumors
are true I'm not natural I enhance my
appearance and if she had said something
like
that that would have killed anything
else someone else can say because she
would have made a joke out of their
attack and so if you're noticing an
underlying theme with all of
this the one thing that counters hate
above everything else is
humor and one of the alltime funny
things that you can always always do is
make fun of yourself and we should
always be better at mocking ourselves
than anyone else does why cuz we have
more material and so just think about
all the things that you can think of
that are adjacent to the insult that
they have so that you can agree with
them and attack even more viciously than
they are to yourself and then you will
appear as the Class Act you will appear
as more humble and they will have
nothing to say back because no one kick
someone who admits their quote faults or
wrongs they look like the bad guy and
then the conflict dissipates now I
walked you through these
examples but I want to give you a
realistic
representation of the proportion of
times that I use 1 2 3 so if this is a
pie chart where I use 1 two and three
one being ignore two being agree three
being agree and one up
for those of you listening at home I
just drew a big circle with the world's
tiniest slice sliced out of it and that
tiniest slice is two and three together
99% of my attention just goes to
continuing to amplify my message people
catastrophize the hate because it feels
like ding we have a lot of strong social
behavior that is bred into us like in
the first things we do as a kid we get
shamed and we correct our behavior and
so when people say bad things about us
we change it feels bad the problem with
social media is that it amplifies that
hate you get a lot of it and so we're
not really built to take that kind of
hate but what we can't comprehend is the
law of large numbers that are associated
if you have a million people who follow
you and you get 500 people who hate you
every single day it's 5% you could
barely even see it on this graph but it
feels like 500 people and that feels
like so many but it's just it's just a
very small percentage of a very large
number the quote I say where you can
only lose if you quit is true again here
if you have reputation the only way that
you can get canceled is if you choose to
accept being cancelled or some external
power makes it impossible for you to
amplify your message meaning if you get
deplatformed from everything and no
platform allows you to post and they
have ai that searches every video that
anybody else makes about you and removes
it automatically yeah you got canceled
but short of
that the only other way you get canceled
is if you choose to accept being
canceled and choose to stop making your
message because on a long enough time
rizon if you keep putting out the value
that you have you keep announcing the
message by percentage of the things that
people are consuming more and more of it
is the positive thing that you're
talking about and so today
it may seem like 50% of the news is bad
but if you take today and then multiply
it by 6 months and it's one day or two
day or 5 days out of 180 days that 50%
was about this negative thing and that
all of the extra was you providing value
providing value then that shrinks the
amount of quote hate or negativity that
you receive and the only way that you
can solve it is through activity is
through advertising in the literal sense
by making your message known hate is a
prerequisite for success just like
Winston Churchill said you have enemies
good you stood up for something sometime
in your life the only people who get no
hate are people who are invisible if you
do nothing that is the only way to
guarantee that you have no hate but if
you stand for anything in your life
there will be people who stand against
you and it is in their nature to attack
and that's okay and so I want to walk
you through this because if you're
dealing with one of these situations
whether it's employee whether it's a
customer whether it's a competitor or
just somebody who just is envious of you
the Playbook has already been written
it's just hard to execute in the moment
but the the more you do it the better
you'll get at it and the tldr is
remember that number one is still by far
the biggest part of this which is you
just keep doing you because if people
know that they can control your behavior
by pushing this button to get this
response from you more people hit that
button you actually let your audience
know and you let your competitors know
and your enemies know that you have
cheat codes that they can dismantle you
but if they can hit any button wherever
they want as hard as they want and
you're going to keep doing you you
become very hard to beat